it's time for roses answers ha hey I
forgot the Rose nay it's fearless wheat
beer carve grains wheat corn potatoes
sweat gymnast either way if I want to be
in The Bachelor I probably shouldn't be
drinking it cuz it'll make me gain
weight I look great on yon but here we
are everybody delicious so I forgot the
Rose Day which means I had a couple
tequila and now I'm drinking this beer
it's a hometown kind of a seal well this
episode of The Bachelor was all about
hometown date let's died in starting out
with Raven and Hoxie Arkansas everybody
guys Raven says that in hoxsey it is
super fun growing up going frog gigging
and grain hopping and coke jumping frog
giggin you go fun strengthened mix
hasn't no idea what he's in for today
Pig singing and all the things a
complete and utter surprise
what is diggin I looked it up on Google
Image it's a lot of dead frog in utter
surprise okay Raven also reveals that
the only place to really open up to
somebody is in a green bin this is a
sacred place and then she says the green
minutes full of secrets
so we need Ravens brother because Raven
and Nikko's tell each other secrets top
the grain bin with a frog giggin and I
thought he was a real police officer for
a second because Raven was a really good
actress the rest of their date consisted
of what I would call a near drowning I
don't know
wasn't it trying to drown Raven in that
bacteria filled water yeast in I'm
tearing of the beer I can't even take a
bath it's just so tepid and
the word for a medium temperature is
attempted I'm like what the words today
everybody so at the other day great mom
a great family Ravens at a very cute
moving on to Rachel well we all know
what this states going to be about I'm
not calling wine they went to regionals
Church and even the pastor to know to
say he was like Nick have you ever been
have you been to a they've been in this
place in its in this space not this is
not this woman okay then we went to
dinner with Rachel family who seems very
lovely sisters mom just the whole crew
to seen great and okra became the symbol
of change Oh God
they said Nick you won't know what Oprah
is Nick said I do know what Oprah is I
have no idea what okra is I just know
that it is okay thank you
sorta and we can all meet in the middle
Rachel doesn't even like okra there was
a super human in here when Nick was like
Rachel I would believe me but you don't
like anything to that drink to knowing
the person you're dating you're meeting
the family up I'm also starting to
realize that each date and like a
special food like Rachel's was okra okra
and Raven would like that right sea
water whatever that water was they were
in next up Corinne who takes us to Miami
Florida and one of the world's most
exclusive malls shopping and Neagle
hand-in-hand anywhere like white on rice
how do you have an exclusive well
the premise of a mall is that anyone can
go to it but that's what I like about
Corinne she makes everything special
like white on rice
so Corinne took Nick shopping and I just
love this because yes this is what curry
wants to do love it yeah love green like
her more and more as the season goes on
I thought she was funny in the beginning
and now I feel like she's getting more
views towards the end
what a great developing story my heart
is gold but my vagine it spun and I
loved when Nick was trying on the
clothes drink this theory stuff to that
because this was the Nick that I know
and love he was so funny with his $800
sweat pants and his weird hat and is
Miami Miami soccer dad you know very
cute Oh big moment we got the elbow
okay drink to that keeps getting real
journey this must be the impetus for gel
and you guys a moment we've all been
waiting for
we met Corinne nany Raquel my nanny
Airtel and Nick used the word infamous
we're all struggling with defining terms
today they wouldn't call retail infamous
I would call her famous I think it's a
myth implies doing it gbmab oh can I say
I loved Quran family drink to her dad
and his olives and his whiskey was
fabulous they seemed very sweet and very
fun and when Corinne said dad I told
Nick I loved him and we've been dating
for months and a half he was kinda like
honey that's only six weeks my mom we
also brought up what Nick used to do for
a living and I forgot then he sold
software which is also at Ben Higgins is
what you selling software it's telling
AOL okay so Koreans adorable dad says
the Korean is the lead to Nick's pot
whatever that means and then he told
Corrine she might have to be prepared to
be the breadwinner of the family he
called it the worst case scenario
sobbing Annie go hand-in-hand
I don't know how to feel about that as a
woman I guess I was a little bit
offended but maybe he just knows who's
got it
but Corrine said she was okay with it
and there was a moment when Corrine said
that she finally felt like with Nick she
found a guy who she was worthy of I
realized I need to get myself a little
more credit
Coran you are worthy strings to Corrine
but at the end of the day Koran family
is super awesome I want them to have
their own reality show and the food of
her date was the olives I think this
means currents Greek her last name is
Olympia last but not least Vanessa we go
to Montreal
I forgot Vanessa was in Canada but
she is and from here on out in the date
I was very confused on her whole
nationality thing is she Italian did she
French is she Canadian how many
languages and which ones does she speak
I don't know but she's good okay so uh
what a moment with her students when
they were so happy to see her I teared
up that was very sweet and I think it's
a work finesse Abed is awesome
cheers to you and then we went home and
there was some very not so subtle like
French cafe music playing in the
background that was a really hard
breakup for me and I don't know was it
free was it aunt was it free music
availability thank my job and we meet
Vanessa's family aka all of Montreal has
come to meet Nick so many people did all
these people get their stag after cards
being on the show oh my god it's a union
so Vanessa is talking with each one of
her many family members and then we came
upon this 80s
poet laureate Frenchman child and I was
transfixed who is this who was this I
missed his intro it's her brother he's
interested and her family is very
concerned and they're talking about the
logistics Vanessa lives in Canada
Nick lives in Chicago LA somewhere and
you know what Kaitlyn Bristowe and Shawn
booth Network we exclusively interview
Kaitlyn Bristowe recently that's
available ETM I'm calm
one shameless plug per video so
Vanessa's family is divorced first we
met her mom's side now we're meeting her
dad's side and her dad is mad yes or no
yeah I don't really know what about but
he's not happy and then it becomes kind
of evident that he might not have seen
the show ever he is very upset that Nick
is asked other woman's parents for
permission to propose I feel like that
happens every season does it matter
and then Vanessa gets upset about it has
she seen the show I don't know one see
the show no French Italian people
whatever they both countries have wine
and so do I normally okay and then we
wrap things up and Ravana is like a very
upset that she's the only one who hadn't
said I love you but I'm pretty sure she
was the first one the same review Oh too
soon but I said it
whatever oh maybe she doesn't remember
we do and Corinne drops Miz a bomb of a
quote we laughed we can giggle I bought
him a really nice outfit god I love
Corinne she's just slaying I want to
fear on paradise we interviewed shad
Johnson and he said that he would love
to see Kareena paradise - check it out
easy on my comm - shameless plug for
videos drink every time you have one and
then we ended these hometown dates with
an out-of-town girl the return ah Andi
Dorfman hello Nick it was about three
seconds long we'll see more of it next
week so those were the hometown dates
everybody we had a near drowning on okra
moly I have no idea no create an
exclusive mall we're shopping at one of
the most exclusive mom's and Italian
tiers very very good I thought all of
the dates had super fun interesting
moments I thought all the families were
super sweet and I felt like we saw next
true connection with each woman so let's
drink to that
[Music]
I think I just gained five down okay
I promise I won't forget the Rose day
next week if you promise to subscribe to
et on YouTube like us on Facebook follow
me on social media if you want and check
out all of our interviews of et
online.com thank you guys so much for
being here seriously we are winding down
not many episodes left and so much more
fun to be had have a great night
everybody bye I don't know why it's the
forum substance and my bike